[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the ohio
plan show powered by icon plus capital
the vc firm and as usual it is sponsored
by block five so you can actually get
pretty amazing interest rates um when
you go to block five much better than
leaving your money in a bank um i think
across europe we have negative uh
interest rates right now so i've left a
link in the description and in i think
if you're watching on twitter it's in
the comments area so um just hit that
and then you can check it out um also
guys if you are watching on youtube
please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe so you never miss
any of these brilliant guests all right
so today we are just going to go for it
we're talking about the market um also
talking about entrepreneurship and
building in this space so joining me
today is the co-founder and ceo of
stacked crypto it is bitcoin but joel
how you doing i'm doing good how are you
thank you for having me
yeah it's great to have you i'm doing
well thank you it's been a while since
we spoke
yeah we're i think
i mean i i think that we i had stacked i
think at the time it was called lunar it
was pre
alpha it was we didn't even have a
product out yet and i think that was the
last time we caught up so it's been a
it's been a long year or so
since then but man crypto it i know we
were we were right
we were right i know and we've spoken
earlier and you were saying everyone is
starting to get rewarded but before we
get into crypto and everything all the
nitty gritty bits um for those that
don't know who you are i know a lot of
people do but for those that don't
please just give us your background and
tell me what you're doing
yeah uh no i imagine most people don't
know who i am um but you know before
crypto i worked a lot in
traditional startups uh inside that
ecosystem i always really was obsessed
with using technology to solve problems
i found myself early stage at grubhub
and spent a lot of years just learning
how to scale a tech business by working
in leadership
leading restaurant growth at grubhub so
at grubhub and working in that startup
environment i came across bitcoin early
on and was in 2015 was
kind of captivated and
you know i like to say the rest is
history i quit my job in uh january of
2018 so for those of us who were around
back then you remember that was the pico
top
absolute best time to walk away from uh
from a nice perfectly well-paying job uh
spent the next 18 months losing all of
my money and a lot of my hair um but
continue to try to find ways to solve
problems
um and ultimately you know i've i've
been a long time investor and enthusiast
in this space i've had my ups and downs
with trying to trade this market
but all in all you know i'm i'm a
full-blown degenerate crypto enthusiast
i love jpegs i love bitcoin i love
coins i love can i say that i don't know
all coins yeah yeah i love you know the
ups and downs i you know i love to mess
around um
you know and have fun with with leverage
when i can and i like to be a long-term
passive hodler i'm a little bit of
everything
uh and i've been operating a ceo of
stacked now for the last uh 18 months or
so
so you said that in 2015 you were
captivated
what got you
well the same thing that i think gets
most people i'm not going to sit here
and you know try to bs about it i needed
well i didn't need i wanted to play
blackjack online and there was this
particular site that i won't give free
airtime to but they're still in
operation today and they accepted crypto
and i knew what bitcoin was i just
didn't care about it um and so i bought
bitcoin in order to
basically play blackjack on this website
it was three or four months later
that um
that the market started to turn around i
basically bought the bottom i mean i
bought bitcoin like two hundred dollars
in september 2015. so
now all of a sudden i see this this crap
that is just sitting in my gambling
account go up in value
what captivated me well number go up
captivated me
make money captivated me right like wow
wait wait a second what is this is this
some new and then down the rabbit hole i
go i obviously got educated on it as a
as a technology in the restaurant
yeah so what always gets me is um people
going full time right because most
people in this space it's not actually
their full-time job um right but i know
a lot of people want it to be and you
know people are always asking me how do
you go full time how did you do it so
that must have been really difficult
leaving a nice comfortable job i know
obviously number go up makes you feel
like it's okay you can leave it keep
going um
yeah but you but you left your full-time
job as the bear market set in and people
don't really know where we are right now
in this market so talk to me about
leaving that full-time job how did you
even know where to go
yeah
so i'm kind of a
lifetime entrepreneur i've always been
fiddling around with technology and
trying to find ways to you know make
money on the internet i was drop
shipping in 2006 on ebay when i was
um a senior in high school so i was a
long time ago right and so i've always
been just
more interested in
products and tech um and like a lot the
idea of like a lot of people using
something that i built then i have been
in
you know money and so for me once i got
to a place where i realized that no
matter what happened with crypto from a
price perspective i was gonna have 12
months of my bills paid i was
comfortable enough to take that risk on
myself because i've always been an
entrepreneur so i've always been doing
that sort of stuff i mean just to get
the opportunity at grubhub at the young
age that i did and move across the
country you know there was a whole story
there so i'm i think i'm good at taking
risks i think if you're if you're a
trader if you if you're if your idea is
i'm going to quit my job to trade
cryptocurrency
then you know i would refer to my good
friends uh don alt or crypto cred uh
some of those guys who have who have
addressed exactly that and what they'll
say is listen if you've been trading
successfully with a track record in a
journal you know you know
able to manage risk you have 12 months
of reserves put away and you have a year
worth of actual trading underneath your
belt and you feel like you could take
the next step who's just i'm not you
know good luck i wish you the best but
it is a loser's game for the most part
it it's one that pareto's principle
definitely applies and the majority of
people 80 or so will lose money um if
they attempt to time the market
um so if you're trying to be a trader
probably don't quit your job unless
you've done what i just said if you're
trying to build if you're if you're an
operator if you're a content creator
you know then the opportunities are
endless in this space take a risk on
yourself go work for a crypto company
get paid in in coins and hope they
go up i mean there's
so much opportunity and i know you can
attest to this if you just dm somebody
if you just meet someone at a conference
you just hop on a google chat
you and i met via dm a long time ago
you've met countless thousands of people
since then just by networking and that
has opened up no doubt countless doors
so
if you really love the space maybe go
get a job in this space you know there's
plenty of companies hiring including
stacked
free plug we are love
good um we'll get we'll get into all of
it um but yeah i think that that's such
a good point people just think that they
can go and trade they lose it all and
then they never come back um but yeah
there are so many job opportunities in
this space um i think dming people is
absolutely the best thing to do i feel
so done with emails i don't know if it's
you but whenever i get an email which is
an essay i'm just like uh
no please
yeah yeah literally we're the generation
of the instant message you know telegram
discord slack text whatsapp that's how i
like to communicate as well just i am me
instant message me let's let's get going
let's move on and you know what that
means that means don't send an essay
like email in a dm
no it's not
just say
say hey birch this is what i need and
then i'll either ignore you uh respond
with something that i need or out of the
goodness of my heart help you out
depends who you are but yeah shoot the
dm over right
no i love it right so stack the hiring
that's cool so tell us about stacks for
those who don't know
well yeah i would love to um stacked
crypto on twitter
stacked is is the world's largest sec
registered automated investment advisor
um in crypto
um
essentially we are a platform that
allows you to put your portfolio on
autopilot it sits on top of your
existing exchange you connect your
coinbase your ftx your ftx us your
binance account to stacked and it's a
much more beautiful and easy to use
interface to manage your assets swap
lend coins on ftx with auto compounding
run trading strategies from some of your
favorite
twitter traders that are out there that
have bots
um you know all that sort of stuff and
recently we secured registration with
the sec so uh we're working on some new
products there that's yet to be
announced but we're working on some new
stuff there as well so
um yeah automation platform for
investing in crypto
so are there any exchanges right now
let's say like binance or ftx like that
that provide that automated service
no and it ultimately it's not their
business that that's fine we're so new
into crypto that it's just inevitability
before more you know companies like mine
are trying to come in and service the 90
percent we talked about pareto's
principal like 47 seconds ago about how
most traders lose money that's kind of
the thesis behind stacked is that
you shouldn't have to be a day trader in
order to be profitable long term in the
crypto space so we're looking to build
tools and user experiences that better
help users adjust their portfolios to
their risk so that way they can have a
better user experience when investing
and they can be more long-term passive
investors i think you can probably
attest to this the secret to success
financially and crypto for most people
is survival it's not catching tops and
bottoms it's not
you know like if you if you catch one
great but it's not chasing and fomoing
it's having high conviction plays that
you hold for extended periods of time um
maybe with some intelligent dollar cost
averaging or rebalancing like different
things that you can do to be more active
but if
there's there's no doubt that huddling
over extended period of time
historically has been the best method so
not trading has historically been the
best we just wanted to build a product
that helps you not trade better right
like huddle better and that's what
stacked is kind of about so it's not a
trader's platform it's not for you to go
into all kinds there's already great
platforms for that uh ftx is my favorite
but um if you're looking for just a kind
of a cool investment experience in
crypto
stacks
so from like a practical and personal
level because i i don't i don't trade if
i was to use stacks how how would i go
about it what value would it offer for
me
yeah so again it's it's
i i like to explain it like this right
let's say you hold money on coinbase and
let's say you hold currently 10 assets
and let's say you decide that you would
like to move half of all of your money
into bitcoin or you name it tether
ripple whatever you're into if you're
like some kind of weird on you're into
ripple
if you wanted to do that today obviously
you would have to log into coinbase go
through that
go into each individual market you know
for each one of those assets sell a
percentage of each one of those things
and that process can take upwards of
several minutes per coin if you're super
efficient but it's also tedious and it's
also inefficient and um it's not a very
i don't know informative user experience
well if your coinbase account is
connected to stacked you can just log in
and move the slider for bitcoin to 50
and stack will automatically
sell whichever assets you tell them you
know unless you like lock an asset and
say don't sell this one it'll rebalance
your portfolio into 50 bitcoin it takes
10 seconds it executes automatically on
coinbase your money is still safe in
your point you know wherever you know
wherever you're holding it um and it
just makes the user experience better so
at the very top it's just a better way
to move money around it gets more
granular from there like buying
pre-built portfolios like our sam
bankman freed basket which is the most
popular one on our website people
connect their ftx account and they
invest in the sam bankman free basket we
all love sam and the basket is simply an
equal weighted basket of sushi serum ftt
and solana which are his four you know
kind of pillar projects and it
rebalances automatically every 30 days
it's up
i can't say like from a compliance
standpoint because i don't know the
exact number but it's up a lot over the
last six and 12 months and so i think a
lot of users just like the ability to
buy a portfolio that's already kind of
built for them
yeah no absolutely okay cool i'm gonna
check this out i love things which are
just simple easy and you can just
explain it to me in the most basic way
like i'm not techy and to be honest
i don't think i think that's a good
thing i don't want to be techy that way
hopefully i can like put the message
forward over to other people you know we
can actually improve the user experience
make things happen um but we're going to
delve into all of this guys remember
joel is hiring so drop him a dm no
essays but drop him a quick dmc's hiring
so that's cool
pretty much every position you can
imagine engineering damn that's exciting
marketing whatever okay cool that's cool
um all right before we delve further
into that i do want to talk to you about
the markets because things are looking
very very interesting right now um
bitcoins at 62 thousand dollars which i
think is great um after that high you
know i think that's
yeah that is just you know holding that
and not dropping down to 55 or anything
like that is really exciting but i'd
love to get your thoughts um well let's
start off with understanding were you
surprised to see a new high
no
um going back to the timing tops and
bottoms it's not my mo i was fortunate
to sell around may a large portion of my
holdings into stables and i was
fortunate to buy a couple months later
just from market cycles but it wasn't
tops and bottoms it was just market
cycle kind of sentiment honestly cobain
who i love on twitter and you know as a
friend
um
you know he kind of called it perfectly
and
just kind of listening to him and some
of the other people we've mentioned
honestly it was just like back in may
was feeling very top-like now as a
result i missed some of the stuff that
happened since then i was not very
exposed to the market and there was a
lot of upside in particular on the nft
space so i kind of slept on some of that
and kind of yeah you know i'm not
claiming to be some kind of prolific
jpeg trader um but yeah that's been
like ultimately uh my experience but the
reason i started buying it back in is
because i said we're for sure retesting
what i'll tell you right now is and i've
been saying this for like the last month
because as being bitcoin birch obviously
my in real life friends and every you
know they always want to talk about
crypto i have no freaking idea i don't
know if it's 100k i don't have 250k i
don't know if it's a million i don't
know where i just know like my
conviction is that what you see when you
look at the bitcoin chart right now is
not what tops look like that's just my
conviction i survived the last top i've
done enough
you know i've i've been exposed to
enough of the market enough of other
markets i think to at least have a high
enough conviction play for myself that
this is not what tops look like and so
i'm not selling here personally
you know um if i'm wrong and things
start to look really bad
maybe i'll change my mind i'll go on
stacked i'll move that tether slider up
to 80
you know and just start auto lending it
on ftx through stacked um in the you
know in the next bear market but
yeah my price prediction is it's going
to keep going up
so
above here and so you know i continue to
like bitcoin
what do you think caused this pump you
know forget like ta and tops and bottoms
what do you think cause it because also
just you know the crash as well i knew
i remember i i put out like an instagram
story back in april and i was just like
i'm so sorry to tell you guys but i'm
just not bullish anymore i was like this
feels like a top but of course you had
the china news elon musk and that kind
of just really tanked the market so what
do you think pumped it this time
yeah well
sometimes nothing has to pump it um you
know it's just sentiment overall
i think you're going to continue to see
correlation to the u.s equities markets
which rebounded in much the same way
um and have followed they're they're
relatively correlated at least lately at
least bitcoin is which the rest of the
crypto market is then also fairly
correlated as we know the bitcoin um so
so i think a lot of it is just maybe
overall market sentiment being positive
right now
um
you know and ultimately the etf
obviously doesn't hurt right the the
bitcoin etf is huge news
now those of us who are in the know
understand that it's kind of uh i think
the word sub for is a toxic product it's
it's not a great product but besides the
point
it is a toxic product yeah it's not a
great product but besides the point it
is a great media headline right and yes
and that media headline does bring
people in who want to buy and i think on
top of that maybe more than anything
bitcoin has really solidified itself as
this
like at least the narrative to bitcoin
is
store value internet gold
well people don't buy gold with the
intention of selling it the next day and
i so what i think you're starting to see
is the mindset of people buying bitcoin
at the retail level is more of you know
i'm just going to hold this i'm just
going to which is good by the way
because i think that's going to be a
profitable endeavor for them so i think
you're just seeing more market
participation
that's the technical answer why does
bitcoin go up well more people were
buying than selling that's why bitcoin
went up and so why were more people
buying maybe etf maybe it's because it
was down 40
maybe it's overall market sentiment
maybe a combination of all of those
things
yeah i'm totally with you i think that
um the narrative around bitcoin matters
and despite the crash that we had it was
the most bullish bear market you know
you have a country adopting bitcoin you
have senators you know speaking about it
even
yeah even even twitter and strike um
that is huge um you know just so much
going on um
so yeah the sentiment is the nft yeah
nfts i actually think have a have a flow
over effect to the overall crypto market
too like obviously there's no
bitcoin nfcs i shouldn't say that i'm
probably going home i'm sure there's
gonna be comment guys like there are
bitcoin nfc they're coming i think
they're coming yeah everything's on
everything on ethereum right now so
everything's on here or solana where i'm
really enjoying nfts lately is on
solana's protocol i love my cavemen and
my apes um but all that to say the nft
craze of the last especially a couple
months but really the last year has been
really driving a lot of participants
into crypto right it's been it's almost
been that mainstream event like the
iphone was or really the ipod was but
the iphone was to the internet is what
kind of brought
nfts are kind of starting to get a lot
of not like a lot of people more
interested and that's just a red pill
and it's just opening the door to more
market participants so i do think
there's some flow
over from the huge success of nfts
um and that market i think naturally
there's got to be spillover into well
now that i own this jpeg like what's
this doggy
maybe i buy some bitcoin and so i think
that can be healthy too
yeah no i'm with you i think that for
some unknown reason nfcs have gone so
mainstream um i i still don't know why
they have um you know you have the likes
of gary vee talking about it
we've got in england we've got um
like really mainstream chat shows which
i just don't watch because i find them
very cringy but even you know the
producers on there are talking about it
um so
why do you think they've gone so
mainstream and also do you think that
they're here to stay
well and non-fungible tokens yes there's
countless use cases for non-fungible
tokens whether it be concert tickets or
pieces of art
validation for physical piece you know
basically act as a certificate of
authenticity for physical pieces of
anything um
and the list goes on
obviously what we're seeing right now in
the overall jpeg market is is bubbly you
know it's got
you know it's bubbly um and i'm not any
type of nft incumbent um so you know i i
have like 80 jpegs in my metamask that's
a lot of 50
i have a lot of jpegs because i'm a
degenerate and i love crypto so if
anything new comes i'm
here you go take my money like let me
how are you picking
how are you picking you're not you're
not just throwing money
you know i think it's important to
understand too that all the money i've
put into jpegs is money that i'm just
like goodbye like this i'm not flipping
i'm not you know i haven't i haven't
dropped six figures on an ape or
anything yet because
i'm just not i don't care enough i just
want to buy stuff that i think looks
cool so i have jpegs of lots of random
art and just cr and just random pfp
profile pictures you know stuff like
that
um you know but i think that a big
reason we see a lot of the price action
is because if you think about it is a
very fragmented market it's a very very
very very low supply market i think um
openc has like 400 000 users maybe i'm
completely made pulling that around my
ass but i don't know but let's say they
have 400 000 users if you take the total
supply of the top 10 nft projects on
openc and add them all together
there's not even enough total nfts to
satisfy
25 of their active user base across
their top 10 projects so
just check this out sorry just to jump
in
openc logs more than a hundred thousand
users a week
new ones
no i think just users a week it just
says here oh and that's their okay
that's a lot of people that's a lot of
people that's 400 000 that's the number
so that's a lot of people
there's not enough nfc like there's
enough nfts but there's not enough of
these like premier
you know five and six and seven figure
nfts to go around and then when you add
the fact that the people who have the
money to spend 100 each on an nft have
the money to spend 100 on a lot of nfts
probably and so
um a lot of the supply is held by you
know you'll see a project with 8 000
pieces that has a thousand unique owners
that's one that's eight pieces to every
one owner and so i think it's a supply
thing too i mean it's the most brilliant
you know like supply and demand
experiment at scale because of this
because social media set it all on fire
garyvee like you mentioned logan paul
whoever right
um and they're fun man like they all
have fun i think some of them are kind
of fun if you're into it i think it's
kind of fun like i've had a lot of fun
playing in the space but be careful like
i'm going to lose all of my money that's
in nfps right now like just so you all
know
um you probably will too so just
you know buy it for the art
it's addictive though because i'm not
actually somebody that's into art at all
um but i'm really into these nft so i
have no i've never bought an nft but
i've got a lot of friends in the space
yeah i've got a lot of friends in the
space and so they'll just like give me
an nft and then we'll just like i watch
the price just go up and people bidding
and i'm just like
i don't want to sell even though i
didn't even pay anything for it i don't
want to sell because i don't know
something about it
and all that yeah you do don't you
especially if you mint it yourself
there's this user experience there's
this gamification that exists in minting
nfts gamification is hugely successful
in ux like in user experience designed
for mobile apps if you think about
robinhood
a company that's done it really well
blockby actually does a really good job
block fully does you know um this
gamification is what addicts people like
i don't think i think there's more
people addicted to call of duty than
there probably are any hard drug on
earth
it's a very addicting thing and so this
this gamification of crypto with nfts
makes something that's already got a
financial incentive and i.e can
definitely motivate you in certain ways
to be more fun or at least feeling more
fun it releases dopamine in a way that
keeps you kind of coming back so
you know who knows where it'll all end
up i think there's a lot more value
creation coming up and you know to that
note open c with 400 000 users as the
number one nft marketplace that's an
irrelevant there are no name
one-off exchanges in like random islands
that have 400 000 users so
um in the crypto space so it's it's it's
such a small number when that number is
5 million 10 million and there's still a
fairly small company from a user
standpoint
that supply and demand issue really
starts to compound and now you start
seeing price you know just crazy numbers
potentially so
and in terms of the market right now so
we have you know nft's booming we've got
bitcoin doing something you know new
highs and all this fun stuff do you
think alts are going to follow
yeah i mean they are
i don't have any reason to believe that
the future won't look pretty much like
the past it kind of has always
um i'm mostly exposed to bitcoin right
now i have been for a little while
because i do feel like it is kind of
bitcoin's turn again it's about that
time of year it's kind of bitcoin's time
here also this is about when bitcoin
likes to do bitcoin things yeah i bought
my very first bitcoin ever in in the
month of september i'll never forget
august 2017 and so forth like bitcoin
loves this time of year so um yeah i'm
going to huddle bitcoin for the most
part and make a couple of other plays
um
you know and then i think alts will
follow and and i hope it's not in like a
blow off top manner you know i i really
like to not see 80 drawdown across the
market again i'd like to see maybe a
little bit more healthy sustainable
growth i just don't know if we're there
yet but i definitely think halls will
fall 100
they always do
i'm so excited for this because i
so today people on twitter were talking
about we need a name for somebody who's
who thinks bitcoin is the best form of
money the ultimate cryptocurrency
yet you don't think that everything else
is a scam so that's me but we don't have
a name for ourselves yet
um we're not bitcoin maximalists um
we're not pointers but we're you
know um
but yeah i think i think it's exciting
because i know it's really funny i was
like should it be i don't know freedom
maximalist that doesn't work um but yeah
it's it's exciting because usually i was
at one point i was only holding bitcoin
whereas now i'm a lot more diversified
and i have a nice amount that i'm happy
with but now i've got quite a few and
even i've got some really really
coins so i'm really excited so i'm
really hoping the best place to be is
with lots of bitcoin and a couple of
really shitty coins i mean i think
that's the best market exposure that you
can have
you know i i don't fault you for that we
all have our favorite but that's the
kind of a part of crypto that i love
like we all have our favorite community
bags too we all have our you know that
one project that caught our high and and
we went for it and it didn't really go
that great from a price action
perspective but here we go
sorry i just removed you from the stream
by accident
yeah no no it was just me
no we can still hear you it's just my
picture um okay so right i want to go
into entrepreneurship now um because for
those who are just tuning in now um joel
is the ceo and the co-founder of um
stacked which is very exciting
yeah that's why i turn my camera off one
sec let me just say that again that's
what i was trying to do there we go so
right joel is the co-founder and ceo of
um stacked they're hiring so drop in the
dm um so let's go into this you left
your job you went full time into crypto
um you know super exciting so
how did you decide that you wanted to
build
a business rather than be a trader or
content creator i know that you said
that you were doing a lot of drop
shipping and stuff anyway but talk me
through you know just deciding yeah this
it's i know i'm an entrepreneur because
a lot of people don't know
whether they have whether they can do it
and you spoke about self-belief so talk
me through that
i think if you're really first of all i
think anything can be taught so i think
if you're not inherently entrepreneurial
i think you can learn it i think you can
be a successful entrepreneur there's
plenty of examples of that with people
with the right mentorship the right
support system the right financial
backing whatever the case may be
um you know you can do that for me like
it was never a matter of um
if i think i can do it or not it was
just like i'm going to do it like it
at the end of the day my attitude and
the attitude of a lot of successful
entrepreneurs that i know
you know have al has always been it
doesn't really matter if if i succeed
that's not really the point like the
point is to do what i feel drawn to do
um
you know with this business like with
this with this idea and all
entrepreneurs have different businesses
and everything else
you know i was creating content um
because i enjoyed talking about crypto
so when i quit my job you know i got a
lot of followers on twitter at the time
and started making friends with a lot of
these other names that you know and that
was great and i really enjoyed um
sharing my opinion about
stuff who doesn't and
i don't know i enjoyed having a lot of
viewership
but when i really reflected i said
do you want to be an influencer or do
you want to be an entrepreneur and in
2020 2021 and in the last
couple of years it's become really sexy
to be an influencer and entrepreneur
and there's like some weird name for it
probably like an entrepreneur or
something we should make one up maybe
talking about names
yeah something like but it's it's
basically people who say they're
entrepreneurs because they have a merch
website or what like what like whatever
the case may be but but they're not like
building businesses what i find is if
you're building and there's different
types of businesses so there's people
who can do both but what i found at
least for my business is in building my
business which now has 40 employees and
you know we've scaled to a certain i
don't have time to be an influencer like
i don't have time to go on i haven't
really tweeted in weeks if you go look
like i haven't been particularly active
on twitter because
it's not important to me to be an
influencer it's important to me to be in
be an entrepreneur so that had to come
first so you know it wasn't like a
decision like do i stop trying to be an
influence review it was just i was
always an entrepreneur i happened to be
talking a lot of shop about crypto
mostly during the bear market and there
was just a couple of us you know talking
about yeah but i always wanted to go and
do this thing and so i went out and did
it and like that's what i encourage
other people if you're wondering whether
you're an entrepreneur or not maybe
you're not you're probably not that
doesn't mean you can't go learn doesn't
mean you can't go work for an
entrepreneur and and see if you like it
dip your toe in and that's what i did
with grubhub i left my my stable life to
go take a chance on a tiny startup to
get involved with a vc funded company
backed by you know smart people
to get experience and i spent a half a
decade there and that was invaluable to
being more of a successful tech
entrepreneur now
so
i think that
it's interesting how
you know because you're
working and you know you're building
this business and you have 40 employees
you don't have time anymore to tweet and
things like that i find that really
interesting because i've been working
with a lot of different ceos to you know
try help build them and things like that
and it's annoying because it's actually
part of being a ceo you need to you need
to be an influencer like you need to
have that power behind you yeah because
that's one thing which i think cz for
example and finance have really nailed
um
because you know he he's obviously not
an influencer but he he has influence um
and so and he he's tweeting all the time
and so i'm always saying to people i
know that you're i know that you're
you're building and this and that but
you have to keep tweeting and
you know elon musk is an example
yeah
he's an influencer
he's an influencer and an entrepreneur
no doubt no doubt and what both you know
when
you know he's also elon musk right and
so
it's not that he has he doesn't make
time for being an influencer he just
tweets whatever the hell comes to his
mind he's a billionaire and a billion
people follow him because he's elon musk
right like if if you know
cz you know cece's one of the rich
people on earth too you know it's it's a
little bit of a different game you know
at my scale
at least to put out any content that i
so on the one hand if i really just said
my mind all the time i piss off
half the people right that's that's how
opinions work like well as as someone
who's trying to get everyone to use my
product and like love the whole
experience i don't want to piss off half
the audience and so i can't just go out
and be
um you know i can't go out and be like
political i can't really be
controversial you know i can't
necessarily chime in on hot topics
because i'm not trying to create enemies
because again business comes first and
you know i want everyone to have a
favorable view of stacked and so that
means they have to have a favorable view
of the guy who started stacked so that's
a part of it so then if i'm going to put
out content that i actually care about
that takes time and right now i don't
value the time enough to do it because
the roi isn't enough to do it so i
definitely agree with you i think
there's so much opportunity there and i
might have to hit you up afterwards
about getting my time better sorted out
so that way i can take advantage of the
of the platform that i've built um but
for me at least in the early stages if
you are someone thinking going back to
your first question about being an
entrepreneur it is really about having
conviction it's really about being able
to put your head down and say it does
not the outcome does not matter if you
get too caught up in will i sell my
company for a billion dollars or will i
go bankrupt it starts to cloud all you
just have to put yourself in a position
to where the finances are sorted because
you know that's something that i think
if you're not financially healthy it's
gonna be really hard um
and then just go for it
you make such an interesting point about
the politics and things that you can and
cannot say
um because it's such an issue that i
think a lot of entrepreneurs are trying
to find that balance
um i think you know if you're an
influencer more say look let's say it's
like um
let's say it's like a spectrum and
you're an influencer here i should make
my hands a bit closer you're an
influencer here and you're an
entrepreneur here the closer you are to
influencer the more you're actually able
to and i think it benefits you to say
these opinions
um
piss people off it's
it works for politics right
but it's interesting because right now i
think that politics is creeping into
every single part of everything that we
do right you know even like identity
politics gender and this and that um you
know coinbase had that whole
issue i can't really remember what it
was but they had a whole supposed racism
issue i don't really know um
so
i don't know like how do you how do you
deal with that you know do you
did you really try and stay away from it
or do you feel you might at some point
get to a point where you know you have
to sort of like take a stand on anything
yeah
so listen like when you when you turn
anything into a business it kind of
reminds some of the fun like i don't i
don't love crypto the way i used to lie
i still love crypto but it's a different
kind of love
i'm a very method like i look at this
it's a business right and you know it's
it's you know so it's it's not free it
used to just be me bitmex 10x yeah
um it's different now you know and so
that's true too if you try to become
like if you're creating content like i
was for fun
and just talking about crypto got a
bunch of people to follow me and then i
tried to turn it into a business because
i had to do that to pay the bill like
you you're in this position as an
influencer if you go full time i'm
saying if you're like this is what i'm
going to do well you got to make money
well to make money you kind of got to
sell out you either got to sell ads you
got to sell ref you got you know
whatever
um so nothing like crazy no like crazy
ico scams or anything but taking you
know uh
shilling a referral link or what and
what what it came down to is for me like
i just hated all of it i was like this
is all stupid i don't think any of the
like i don't want you to use my ref link
to trade on bitmex because like you
probably like that's not
you lose money disingenuous it just
wasn't for me personally right and also
keep in mind
i'm not an anonymous twitter person yeah
and some of the biggest names that you
see ruffle the most feathers and get the
most
hyperbole really you know going on are
people who are hiding behind the veil of
a cartoon account which is fine and i
actually i'm very close friends with a
lot of them and totally understand why
why they are not thoughts
and i totally support their decision to
not be doxxed but as a result they don't
suffer the same personal consequences
for their opinions uh like i will as a
public-facing ceo of a
of a
well-backed tech business like i i just
can't play the same politics so i think
if you're gonna do it you just gotta be
genuine you just and so for me me me not
tweeting for a week is genuine sometimes
and then you'll see sometimes if you
follow me like i'll go off for days like
i'll just i'll tweet 100 times a day for
a week and then i'll disappear for a
month that's just me that's just genuine
that's just right now i care and
tomorrow maybe i don't care and today i
love your nfp tomorrow i don't probably
care about it
that's just me being just me being me so
you just gotta be yourself i think i
mean you just can't go out there and
like try to
i don't know
fake it like you'll get ripped apart
oh absolutely yeah especially crypto
twitter it's toxic and we know who we're
talking about there's fakers and there's
larps right there's like people we and
we know and the community knows and
sometimes i wonder if the larp
themselves knows that we all know
because sometimes they tweet like
like they're acting like we don't know
it's true it's true and you really do
get ripped apart so you know integrity
um is essential but in terms of just
building this business because i'm sure
there are a lot of people listening
thinking you know i don't want to be an
influencer i want to build something
that people can actually use um what are
some of the biggest challenges that you
came across and also challenges that you
didn't expect
well i'm building a tech product so the
challenges were largely people
like talent specific like finding the
talent to build a tech product um and
then obviously you know solving the
problems in tech and i'm not natively
tech i'm a self-taught front-end web
developer i don't know anything about
pretty much anything so um yeah the
challenges are i'm not a finance guy and
i'm not a tech guy and i'm going to
build a finance tech company
that's a challenge in and of itself so
how do you solve for that you surround
yourself with people who are just
gigabrains so sam bankman freed um
the earliest supporter of stacked we
were the earliest supporters of him and
alameda and ftx and we built a good
relationship with that whole team as a
result and that's been invaluable the
same goes for like countless other
connections that we have in crypto
the
entire breadth of our success is due to
our friends on twitter you know people
who have like shared our product our
investors like sam and and jump cap you
know other like really really great
investors and big announcement coming
soon on that front um and just a great
network hiring people like i am just
good at like bringing people together
i'm pretty much crappy at every
individual thing
and so if you understand that as an
entrepreneur like where your strengths
are and you
plug in people in your weaknesses then
you have a real shock at doing something
but it's you know it is kind of a team
after like you're going to have to reach
out very likely and start building that
network if you want to have a real shot
at like you know building something it's
a huge challenge
that's so spot on you know surround
yourself with good people that you can
add value to and they can add value to
you you know it's a good give and take
relationship is so important but it's
actually really hard i know for me you
know i find it i i took like a huge dive
into crypto and lost honestly a lot of
friends because they didn't get it
it's a whole new mindset and so it's
very difficult to surround yourself with
not just like-minded people but you know
intelligent people and that it just
works with so
even hiring people is hard so
you know how do you go about finding
good quality people
yeah
so this i don't know how this will come
off to the audience but like yeah it is
hard
like that's why most people won't
succeed at what you're doing or what at
what i'm doing
because it is super hard and it takes a
long time like think about all the hard
work you put in to get to 150 000
followers on twitter and crypto mostly
during a bear market that's hard like
and so that i want to make sure that no
one listening is going to be mistaken
for the fact that there may be an easy
way to get rich trading to get rich
being an entrepreneur a content creator
an influencer or whatever
it's just
first and foremost understand if you're
listening to this because you have
inspiration to be full-time and crypto
or an entrepreneur understand first and
foremost it is freaking hard and and it
will test you in ways that i that i
cannot begin to to to make a parent to
you
how do you get over it when you mention
hiring particular
try really hard uh ask people go on in
email dm phone call google youtube find
recruiters in my case i i went to my
board you know who are again people who
i surround myself who have business
career hey give me some great recruiting
companies i don't have any recruiters
in-house and i need to hire rockstars
that's what they did they introduced me
recruiting companies you write the check
they send the candidates and then you
figure it out you know and so it depends
on what stage you're at but i think
embracing the fact that it's super hard
and that there isn't maybe just one way
to go about solving for that
is part of being an entrepreneur like i
can't give you the roadmap because it's
so different for everybody all i can
tell you is it's going to be really hard
and you'll probably fail and if you
still go for it after hearing and fully
understanding that you're probably going
to make it
because that alone saying like hey it's
really hard you're probably going to
fail that gets that weeds most people
out yeah yeah you're right
see myself out so
i don't know you just gotta you gotta
want it in some kind of way or you gotta
be super lucky like do not get me wrong
there are people out there who just in
spite of them have just fallen into
absolute you know gold mines and
businesses and that's great you know god
bless them
yeah is there anything that you would do
differently or any mistakes that you've
made that haven't added value in the
long term oh sure sure sure
um yeah i tend to be like ask alan or or
steven or any of my guys on my team like
i tend to be
um pretty like like i'll get it i'll get
an idea and it's like let's let's do it
and let's start like moving towards it
before it maybe is fully flushed out and
then it's like yeah maybe and so i tend
to move maybe too quickly that's
definitely a weakness sometimes it can
be a strength definitely but yeah
sometimes as a weakness um but you know
there's tons of things i would do
differently like in hindsight we've made
bad hires we've made bad
we've made some really good decisions i
think on like the investment side of our
business but yeah you make some bad
hires you make some poor product choices
you go with the wrong vendor
countless stuff you know um that i would
ultimately do differently um i never did
a token for stacked
i think that's a good thing no yeah
in hindsight i wouldn't do that
differently back then but now that i
didn't do it back then and i have the
resources to maybe do it correctly now
it's something that i maybe will explore
so i don't i don't know if we can drive
real value to users and be compliant
then definitely something we'll explore
but i don't think i regret not doing a
token either even though it would have
surely put tens of millions of dollars
in the pockets of like all the early
people here but
um
yeah well my thing with tokens well as
you can say like my thing with tokens is
i often find there's a lot of companies
that often have a token for the sake of
having a token just to keep you in the
ecosystem that really annoys me though
like as a user i don't really that
doesn't really add any value to me
that's like 95 percent of tokens they
have a token just now
yeah that's why i said i'm glad you
don't have a token yeah no it's a
crowdsource it's a crowdsourcing
mechanism that's what i'm getting at is
like if i were to do it i'd do it right
like if it's a crowd if it's a if it's a
funding mechanism i'ma let you know like
this is a funding mechanism i'm not
going to try to hide it behind the veil
of some you know bs white paper that's
going to say it's going to do this
yeah there's very few examples of tokens
that are not tokens just to be tokens
and so i totally agree that's why we
haven't done it because
um that just wasn't part of our mission
and keep in mind too we're a us-based
like regulated
we're trying to build a very specific
product for a very specific user
so when we look up we're inspired by
block five by m1 finance by coinbase um
none of whom have tokens exactly so
um for me and for this business today
that's you know that's where we're at
but like i said because of the product
we're building and the ecosystem we're
building in especially on the
decentralized version of stack that
we're working on there may very well be
a real utility for a token and we'll be
excited to explore that
yeah as long as there's real utility and
real value for could you imagine like a
decentralized stack right stacked is a
great product you still have to connect
to your centralized exchange in order to
use it right and
but we would love for you to also be
able to connect your metamask wallet and
and hold or your or your ledger right
and actually hold your keys and still be
able to take advantage of those tools
well in doing so we'd have to build some
type of you know blockchain solution and
in doing that there may be again a real
a real need for a token so stay tuned
you know stay tuned all right so just
finally what advice would you um would
you give to people um
looking to go full time looking to
potentially build um you've given a lot
of advice but just one sort of main
overall to
to end the conversation
i you know surround yourself with good
people uh like i said find a find a
partner maybe not even one that's a
friend when me and my business partner
went to business together we weren't
friends we weren't like not friends we
were just a point we just met we were
just like acquaintances
yeah well we've become brothers right
like we've become very close but so you
know find people who are speaking your
same language that that can help your
your mission um and have conviction
um
you know you you have to really believe
it in your core and be like moving
towards
you know something that's inspiring to
you you know for us it's reinventing
really the way that you know retail
investors interact with long-term crypto
investments
active indexing you know tax loss
harvesting like really bringing
traditional finance tools to crypto
because it's needed that that drives me
it's something i'm passionate about so
you should do that and and then you'll
probably find it if you go out and try
to start a business with the sole
purpose of making money
in my experience it can be harder to
make money if you go out with the
purpose of solving a problem in my
experience if you solve that problem the
money will follow because people are
willing to pay for the solution but if
you have money driving your motivation
it will cloud how you go about the
solution because you may decide the
solution requires x y or z that it that
maybe it really doesn't and so just
again try to be like really clear in
your mission and your purpose and what
you're working towards and go into it
with that mindset and then fail forward
fail fast and feel forward if you feel
it you know if you screw it up drop it
if it's wrong that's a tweet i should
tweet that
yeah maybe i will you should tweet that
you should do that once we get off you
should tweet um
what did you just say no before that
you're like something it's something
fast
and then fail fast and fail forward yeah
yeah tweet that see that once we get off
okay you want to fail fast you want to
fail forward that is my advice there you
go it's good
um yeah and you'll be fine
yeah
even for those who aren't necessarily um
building a business like you did but are
um you know just trying to go on their
own whatever it is um having that
conviction and also putting value before
money is so important um and then
i guess we'll just just add this bit at
the end here it's also knowing when to
say no um
and understanding that actually it's
okay to turn down money if it doesn't
add to the final goal so you have to
know okay what is my goal is my vision
if it doesn't add to that turn down the
money otherwise it's a waste of time and
it won't sit right with you um
and your integrity you know
with with us pre-revenue pre-user
pre-money bootstrap bear market bitcoin
three thousand dollars we had someone
offer to buy half our company for seven
figures invest seven figures for half
the business at a time where we needed
it desperately at the absolute worst
part of crypto history
um it didn't align you know at a higher
level with our with our vision uh and we
turned that money down and i as a result
didn't pay myself and neither did my
founder for another six months um you
know and in hindsight that decision
saved me literally tens of millions of
dollars so
um yeah i think you're 100 right know
when to say no like know when to again
have that conviction and understand what
your mission is
um you know
and that's really the best you can like
and at the end of the day i i've started
saying this more recently but i'm very
guilty as an entrepreneur of over
indexing myself and like over like
working too hard and taking it way too
seriously and putting an 80 hour wait
and like just going crazy crazy crazy
i'm obsessive compulsive and a lot of
entrepreneurs are the same way but i
have to remind myself sometimes a
colleague of mine someone who works for
me said this the other day he was hey
it's just a job
like
at the end of the day stacked
it's just my job it's an important job
that is you know has all this story and
has all this
you know risk reward but it's just like
at the end i got my wife you know you
know i got my family i got my friend and
like
so when when you when you tackle this
full-time thing whether it's content
creator entrepreneur whatever just
remember like at the end of the day like
try if you like trying to take it too
seriously like still live your it's just
your it's just a job you know what i
mean sure
yeah it's true where can people find you
and how can they get involved in stacks
well we'd love for you to check out
stacked we're launching aggressively in
the us we've only recently started
supporting coinbase and ftx so more and
more products coming there but if you're
especially if you're a normal ftx or a
buybit user uh stacked is huge for you
uh you can go to
tristact.com and you can just follow me
at bitcoinbirch on all platforms if you
if you want i don't talk as much as i
used to
you know i know you're going to get me
back into it so we'll rock and roll
i will do i will do guys go follow joel
on twitter um and yeah joel thank you so
much for coming on it's been so
interesting i love to talk um
entrepreneurship business because it's
you know everybody wants to achieve more
a lot of people want to achieve more and
it's very difficult sometimes to have
these conversations um with people in
your immediate vicinity so yeah thank
you so much for coming on um and
sharing your your experience with us
anytime thanks for having me as always
and guys thanks so much for tuning in
please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe on youtube so you
never miss a video i will see you next
week alright bye
[Applause]
[Music]